so anyway would either of you two like
to say anything about forms do you have
any input before we ask the
clerks simply what we all know and that
is because 80% of the uh litigant in Pro
in family court or prosay the easier the
better the easier to fill out especially
since the court says you well know are
sure-handed
um despite the generous race we gave you
and I've talked to the head of Finance
uh don't be surprised two years from now
either um there may not always be people
right there to translate the forms so
the forms need to be obvious and it's
something we all know
but there it
is representative ball thank
you so I'm just looking at the um the
Court's page where it does have the form
and I guess I the question I would have
is if these forms when I pull them up
they don't seem to be um fillable online
do you it's like they have to be printed
out rather than filling them out right
online and then printing them um or
saving them as a PDF and I don't know
how that is and then the other question
I would have is just how are we
educating the public to actually find
them if they come in and um or they want
a file for something I'm just wondering
how do they know that this even
available to them as opposed to they
have to hire an attorney right away to
find
this yes uh thank you first of all for
your interest in this topic uh forums
are something that we obviously use
every single day and that
self-represented uh litigant in
particular uh we hope we'll find sorry
could you go ahead and introduce
yourself just so that we have that
apologies thank you so much uh yes I'm
the senior Circuit Court Administrator
Heather kulp uh and so I work with judge
king whom you heard from last week on
managing the Circuit Court processes Etc
um and really our expert today is uh
elain low who's our clerk from OIP and
Conway on uh forms and on on uh user
experience with form so I can speak to
kind of policy and practice issues um
from there
so we offer a few different ways that
folks can learn how what forms are
needed for a particular case step in
family division um so one way is our
divorce and parenting website for
instance will include the list of forms
that's needed to complete a divorce and
parenting case and it's hyperlink to um
to the exact form that's needed um some
of those also have instruction sheets
along with it so it's it's not just what
forms are needed but also there's some
instructions for how to complete those
so that's one way is directly on our
website for divorce and parenting for
instance uh you'll see that list of
forms that's needed um we also will
print out and provide forms at the
courts themselves for folks so if
someone comes in and and says I have a
parenting case I want to uh work through
parenting issues with the other parent
of my child um we will Point them to the
correct forms and can print print out
those forms for them as well um and then
we also have court processes that will
uh provide them with the forms directly
so if they file a petition for divorce
for instance uh the P the court staff
person putting together um uh their
initial packet will send them forms and
we'll send them a list of the forms
that's needed to complete their case so
even if they file one one petition
opening a case um we can point them to
the appropriate forms um did that answer
your question representative
ball yes and I'm I'm looking at the um
the list of forms I just picked up I
don't even know which one I did divorce
and parenting and I noticed that the
forms are all um in alphabetical order
but I'm wondering if there's any type of
a road map um that you give to people at
the courthouse or that they're somewhere
on this website that might actually lay
it out in very easy terms in a visual of
like if this then that and then these
are the forms just because if they're in
alphabetical order I think it's kind of
hard for people to figure out which do I
have to fill out all of these you know
so that's my question and you can feel
free to use that computer if there's a
page that you want to bring up to kind
of show or to demonstrate that would be
fantastic too so feel free to use that
computer great yes maybe we'll do that
would you mind bringing up the divorce
and
parenting um web page that has the list
of
forms and so if you go to the Court's
website and if you want to switch seats
we can do that as well why don't we do
that
okay
so I I'll try to narrate as I'm doing so
for the purpose of the record um so I'm
going to the Family Division
website and if you go to the divorce and
parenting page there it provides
information for someone going through
divorce or parenting case uh about both
the process and then also the forms that
might be needed so if I am uh seeking a
divorce I can click on how do you file a
divorce petition and that will bring up
the list of apologize for my slow
scrolling uh that will uh bring up a
couple other options so for instance do
you have minor
children uh I will select
yes and then that guides me to how to
start my divorce proceeding and how to
complete my divorce proceeding including
the list of forms available there
um so it takes a little bit of the
guesswork out of that alphabetical order
of
forms um to have the information kind of
guide people through a list of questions
that they may need to answer before it's
determined what forms are
needed thank
you how'd you get to that page because
when I went on um on
mine intuition is telling me to just go
right here where says forms and fees M
and then I I've lost I didn't come
across that at all so maybe it's
something right here on this front page
that
somehow we need to direct people better
or am I maybe it's a difference between
no you have a computer versus an iPad or
something it looks
different um I
don't yep so our courts and then the
Family Division up here so it's in the
main menu but I appreciate your
recommendation about
um about where you intuitively end up on
the website I thought you were talking
about the website I'm like no it doesn't
say ords okay see
I as a person not
familiar not ever going to go there I I
saw this as being see how this is much
bigger forms and fees
boom it might just be a matter of making
the actual page
um a little bit easier to understand for
people who are not familiar with
courts and I should say too that we know
that because uh judge Ashley was here um
graciously spent some of our time and
talk to us about that you guys are
looking at forms I do understand that
before each of the courts kind of had
their own forms so one of the processes
you guys went through was to bring all
the forms to where every Court had the
same forms which is super helpful and
now that you've got them all that at
least the same it's about kind of going
through them and she talked about you
know going through the highest use forms
um the family lens the most frequently
filled out incorrectly I do know that
you guys kind of have a system that
you're starting to work through and I
believe she said that this month you're
starting rfps on somebody that will help
you guys do that is that correct yeah I
believe the schedule is this month I'm
not in charge of the RFP process in that
in that way so I'm not sure exactly when
it will be released but yes that project
is in progress okay and the goal is six
to nine months that's what I believe she
said that's my understanding okay um do
either one of you have questions
specifically for the clerk go ahead um
forms and fees when fees are to be paid
how are they paid do they are they paid
somehow simultaneously with filing a
form you send us a bill do we wait to
see who wins and hopes the other one
gets stuck with court card how does this
work so the my name is Elaine low I'm
the clerk of the circuit courts in
Conway and oopy um also act as the case
manager in Conway um so the FI when the
forms are filed the filing fee is
required at the time of filing so we
either get a check cash or credit card
if a part is unable to afford the filing
fee then we offer a motion to wave that
fee um it's filed with a uh financial
affidavit and and then once the judge
reviews both and a ruling is made on the
motion to wave the filing fee it's
either accepted as um waved in full we
send parties a notice that part of the
fee is due or the motion is denied
completely and the case doesn't go
forward until the filing fee is
considered paid or
waved follow up um that's for the forms
what about a piece of evidence someone
has and wishes to say submit that is
there a fee to that there's a fee to
open a case there's no fee typically to
file into that case Okay so exhibits
evidence motions there are no no fees
for that type of so court costs then uh
does that apply in this state at this
level does it mean just the opening
filing the phrase court costs that one
hears I think often when people are
referring to court costs I imagine they
may also referring to any attorney's
fees that are related to the court
proceeding um but I would have to hear
it in context to be able to comment so
court cost may be fees to file or fees
to reopen the case um which may occur if
the case has been closed and then
someone files uh to change the parenting
plan or modify child support or
something like that after the case has
been closed thank
yes and so you work Direct IR ly with um
people that come in like prosay litigant
and stuff do they come in there now I
know that in conquer they had a computer
that they can come in and kind of sit at
and stuff are you approached with many
questions or do you find that people are
just kind of filling them out and
guessing and hoping they did it right or
do are people actually coming to you and
asking like what do I do with
this so it's probably um an even amount
of both most people come to the court
with their form to our courts mine at
least with the form completed um they
have some questions sometimes they'll
come to the counter I want to file for
divorce what do I need and we provide
them the forms but uh surprisingly a lot
of people show up with the forms um
partly completed Miss now are
you limited or what is your scope of
what you can advise someone on like if
somebody comes in and says okay I'm
getting divorced and I don't know what
to do what is it that you've been told
that you should do like what are your
parameters for helping someone so of
course I can't I can't give them legal
advice right um but I can explain to
them how to fill out the forms okay
um the forms all work in conjunction so
a divorce for example PE uh litigants
are required to file Financial
affidavits the financial affidavit
information is directly relate um to the
final decree so any debts assets um has
to also be related related in the final
decree
so that basically all I can do is tell
them here are the forms I I can help you
fill in the blanks with the information
you give me um but that's about what I
can do is there somewhere that you refer
them to like is there a specific place
on the computer or we have a list of
unbundled attorneys that we provide we
have a list of um legal referral places
that we send them to I mean we give them
the information when they file um and
then we refer them to mediation if um if
there are questions that I can't answer
a mediator can go a lot further than I
can in a case manager
conference and what about um do you
notice a particular pattern and
difficulties as far as when people come
in proos with forms not particularly not
in my situation at least you know but
Conway and oopy I would imagine bigger
locations where there's more money
involved um the the issues are a little
different but not in my particular
locations okay any
question representative B do you have a
question about any of
that you're still putting out to bid for
help in
updating your
forms yes that's correct so I'm not sure
exactly when the RFP will be released
it's not released yet but yes but you
probably already have a list mental or
written of forms you would suspect would
be updated
yes we have about 1100 forms so it's
it's quite a list um and there are
certainly forms that we know uh people
have expressed difficulty around or we
know that they're complicated to fill
out even if we do need all the
information on them the financial
affidavit is a good example of that
where we we need all the information
requested but the the format could
certainly be improved the language could
certainly be improved so all of those
are the things that we're looking at in
this project as the um chairman of the
special
committee um I'm happy
that some of the things we've
identified as areas of improvement you
folks are doing the same and that's
wonderful but before I say okay let's
declare Victory and go home uh just want
to make sure is there a way that we as a
subcommittee or as the entire special
committee can work with you during the
process uh because there are people who
use broad General nasty language and
then there are the occasional individual
who was a specific reference to
something I'm just wondering if we can
keep the lines open and work on this
together with what we know as outside
eyes and ears with you folks who live
with it every day yeah thank you and I
think um one of the valuable pieces is
that your work has done chairman is is
draw out some of the concerns and and
kind of label them in broader categories
and so if you've heard particular
concerns about some of the forums that
you'd be willing to share with us so
that we can uh look at that and make
modifications as is appropriate to
increase access that's that's what we
want to be continually doing um in our
process so if you have some of those um
areas for improvement that you've
identified we would certainly welcome
that um and we welcome anyone who has
used these forms or looked at these
forms and chosen not to use them because
they're complicated or confusing uh we
welcome feedback on those forms from
those individuals I intend to find a
half a dozen
individuals who are just starting
through this process and ask them to
give me feedback along the way that then
I can be that extra set of eyes and ears
with you folks but again this is just
one example of the general Co
cooperation my committee has found with
the
Judiciary um it's been
uniformly uh well first of all I I
approach this as a collaborative Venture
rather than an antagonistic one and that
beg got the same but also um the
willingness to say we're not perfect and
we want to make it better so let's work
together so that's been uniform so far
and I'm very grateful for that I've read
um minutes from other states where a
special Committee in the Judiciary
became highly antagonistic and uh we're
not doing that either side so thank you
so much well we're all dedicated to
increasing access to justice for folks
so I'm grateful for our opportunity to
do so together good so if I could have
uh would you be the one who would be the
ones making sure it's in a form of a
question who would be the ones that we
would call contact should we come up
with a specific once this process is
rolling uh names and contact information
who should we call I think the primary
contact has been the um AOC email
address I think that's been the the
filter because then um the
administrative office of the courts can
make sure the recommendation gets to the
appropriate trial court or Supreme Court
um for uh for forms uh review thank you
thank you and you'll Supply that to us
yes I will absolutely Supply that to
both of you and then also you do have
some you I think judge Ashley said that
you would be having public input how is
that going to work just so that when
people do come up we can kind of
reassure them yes that's part of the RFP
will be uh that who whichever entity we
engage with to uh do this work with us
would identify a way to receive public
input on the forms
um so I can't specify at this point in
time just because we don't know yet but
I imagine it would probably be something
like an email inbox or a public forum or
something like that um to receive input
and we receive input regularly from um
from individuals and also from Court
staff that see people tripping up on
things and make recommendations okay so
it's it's part of our ongoing process of
improvement perfect do either of you
have a question or any more input or
anything oh
not immediately related to this but
while you're here um let's suppose this
is a hypothetical let's suppose an
individual uh now let me start with a
question when does small claims end and
not small claims
begin in terms of suing someone for
money what what case constitutes a small
claims Cas yes
yes so uh Superior Court is is over the
$25,000 Mark Superior code is 25k and
above how about Circuit Court Small
Claims jurisdiction is up to
10,000 is this why um I'm trying to make
sure it's an answer you can give me uh
is this why um I have heard that some
folks who were going to sue for 12,000
decided they didn't want to go to the
Superior Court dropped what they asked
for down to 9500 so as to keep it small
claims in Circuit Court does that track
with what some people might likely do um
I can't speak to what individuals might
choose to do a but that's certainly
something that someone could do if they
chose to forgo an amount over $110,000
they could then file uh for a small
claims case in Circuit Court up to
$10,000 thank you very
much representative ball do you have any
questions or any more
comments okay can we take questions from
yeah okay yes honorable Betty gay do you
have a question thank you when I got a
divor years ago um there was Betty could
you come up to a microphone given your
you can go over to this side I I am
sorry that is not my place to do that
that's okay I'm gonna let that go
because I didn't know what to do yeah if
you could just turn that microphone on
[Music]
yeah I was offered a prosay packet so I
was wondering do they still do some of
the courts that a person's going to file
a divorce in still have that option to
receive a packet which of course
contained forms not necessarily as much
instruction as might be handy but is
yeah how much is done to help prosay
people so we provide the forms T
typically people will come in and file a
petition for divorce um there are a lot
of forms we we try not to inundate the
petitioner with all the forms at once
because it's a lot so once we get the
service process done um we then schedule
a case manager conference or or
something we can um if it's a case
involving children we conduct first
appearance so that allows the case
manager to determine which path the case
is going to take at that point um at any
time that the proos say litigants want
all those forms we are happy to provide
them um usually we do that when uh
parties file joint petitions because
they're already in agreement to sign the
divorce petition so we provide all the
forms that they would need to finalize
their divorce um does that answer your
question that answer your question or do
you have a followup followup sure um you
were you're mentioning terminology that
I don't know I apologize so no no you
have to because that's part of the
procedure but is there any any
instruction sheet that says this is the
first step then here you have more steps
then here you have more steps more
options so that people have some idea
about what steps they will have to do so
as the process moves forward like right
from the beginning we if parties have
children then their once service is
accomplished we in the service packet is
all that information you can go to
mediation this is you know first it says
that you can go here's an option correct
here's your other option and and when
the cases where there are children
there's a
flowchart um that advises people where
the case could go from that point and
who which court handles that so the
Circuit Court provides um whoever
processes the divorce and initially will
send that information out to the to the
parties I'm just trying to get a picture
of how extensive the uh outline is like
you say you get a flowchart so is the
flowchart pretty complete on on all the
potential paths you might take for cases
that involve children yes okay yep and
and that's available um it on the
Court's website and first appearance
video that is posted on the
website yeah even the first all these
terms are so helpful to have them
defined in step one step two step three
or four yeah so we try to provide that
as the service packet goes out a lot of
that information goes to the parties
okay thank you you're welcome thank you
I did have one specific question that I
know somebody else on the special
committee had about the difference
between when you're going for a
protection or order where it was
stalking versus the form for stalking
versus the stor uh the form for domestic
violence or domestic abuse and I guess
the person that they knew had filed the
wrong one they should have filed now is
that something if they came up and they
they had these two forms that are kind
of confusing because it says based on
RSA which they might not know what the
RSA is and what that entails that they
could say this is my situation I don't
know which form to fill out is that a
question you can answer them or would
Point them how would you point them in a
direction to know which one to fill out
so we um advise all parties that come to
court to file either of those protective
orders we refer them we make an initial
referral to the um ad to the advocacy
groups the um because they can listen to
the story and figure out which form
we're not allowed to pick and choose
which forms we can provide them each
form or both forms um and the court has
um those c those instruction forms on
the website that kind of dictate which
form you would file in in a different
situation that makes sense I'm glad to
hear that the first step is to you know
Point them to an advocacy group that can
kind of help them more with that I know
that's more complicated all right does
anybody else
have so um I thank you for coming today
I know you took a lot of time out to
come here thank you so I think based on
what we heard from Judge Ashley last
week what we're hearing from them I feel
comfortable in saying that I don't know
that we need to do anything except for
just keep the lines of communication
open if we have a specific concern we
can reach out I will make sure that you
both have that email and we'll just keep
in touch with that does that work for
everyone yes all right thank you then I
will bam conclude this conclude this
subcommittee meeting thank you all so
much for your
time